and one of the thoughts that continually
gets me to the gym and continually makes
me show up and work hard
is and if you're good at it if you're
great at it
then you might just be great at
everything but for me that really is the
meaning of life
on this week's podcast we're going to do
something very different something i've
never done before but something that
you've requested time and time again
this week i posted online asking you to
ask me any question
about me my life my business whatever
you want to ask me
and i promised that in return i would
give very brutally honest answers
my team went through all of the
questions that were submitted and they
went through and picked ones that they
thought were most interesting
they've written them in my diary here so
i'm going to start from the top and
answer these questions with the
objective of giving you the most
valuable
honest advice that i possibly can so
without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diver ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
okay so the first question is what is
the most important lesson that this
pandemic has taught you
or reconfirmed for you and for me
that is um it relates back to a podcast
i did at the start of the year and it's
that uncertainty is not predictable but
it's
preparable and i don't actually think
that's a word but here's what i mean
what i know for sure and this relates to
everybody is that your life
is of course going to be full of a lot
of joy and amazing things and
breathtaking moments and rapturous
moments of
of ecstasy right but it's also going to
be riddled with
moments of unexpected uncertainty and
chaos
joy is much easier to handle you just
kind of let go and go with it right the
good times
not a lot of action or thought required
but uncertainty and chaos require a real
rigid set of principles and
for me those principles over the last 12
months have become
acceptance optimism and action and these
three principles have a real linear
connection to the outcome you're seeking
without acceptance when bad things
happen
there's no optimism without optimism
there's no action and without action
there's often no victory or at least
victory is delayed and hard times are
elongated so when bad news visits
whether that's being unexpectedly
fired from your job or jumped by your
partner or evicted by your landlord or
losing a loved one in the case of a
pandemic
you have to do everything you can to
stick to these principles despite the
intense cloud of natural emotions that
will try
to convince you and me otherwise and you
know like i do
a lot of sort of introspective thinking
for a living and even
i am not immune from letting emotion
get the best of me in times of intense
chaos
i like no matter how much i've read or
written in my diary or how many podcasts
i've done
even i fall victim especially in the
short term
to all of those emotions and sometimes
to the the
instructions those emotions give you
which will lead you to um
to pretty dire outcomes so you know you
get dumped by your partner you
immediately think revenge right you get
fired by your boss you think
um you know i'm gonna sue them right i
fall for those traps too
and i don't think i don't necessarily
think it's the aim of all humans should
be to try and avoid
those emotions and that thinking because
i think it's quite impossible but it's
to be better at the response right to
shorten the time that those emotions sit
with you
and to be better in your reaction and i
want to clarify that acceptance when i
talk about acceptance it doesn't mean
being emotionless
it can often mean the exact opposite you
have to accept how you're feeling except
what's happened
and importantly retire from trying to
change the unchangeable
or from wallowing in regret and you have
to do everything you can to get yourself
to a place of optimism i see that as
your responsibility
people won't like me saying that right
people typically especially in hard
times don't like to delegate
responsibility to themselves
so as hard as it can be you have to find
and create hope for yourself
and have faith just like everything else
has in your life that this
too shall pass and then you have to use
that optimism
to drive you into action which is for me
the third principle that i've learned
over the last 12 months if your
partner's dumped you it's time to dust
yourself off and get yourself into the
gym
to fight back and i don't mean fight
backers in bomb their house i mean fight
back
in a mental capacity to stop stalking
their instagram to triple down on your
friendships and
your meaningful relationships to stand
tall and
weather the unavoidable emotional storm
and have faith
and acceptance sit by your side the
opposite
of these principles of course is like
denial is pessimism and is in action
and these are the principles of a baby
gazelle that's decided to fall asleep
with its toes dipped into a
crocodile-infested waters this is a
decision to lose twice and when i say
l right i mean loss and when unexpected
chaos happens like this pandemic which
smashes our businesses and destroys our
social lives and apparently steals a
year from
from our youth the first l we take is
involuntary
[ __ ] happened and you didn't choose it
totally out of your control i get that
but the fateful decision to choose
denial
pessimism and inaction as our response
is a voluntary second l what you're
choosing to increase the chances
that bad times will become even worse
times you can make the choice
not to lose twice the first l wasn't
your choice the second l
well that's the byproduct of of how you
choose to respond
acceptance optimism and action
and i guess the second lesson i've
learned this year is a lesson in the
importance
of prioritization you know this advice
of
which people often given i've often
given of protecting your time and saving
your time really feels somewhat
incomplete to me now because
it's like the first half of the sentence
you've got to then ask yourself
saving time to do what saving time just
to spend more of it doing the wrong
things
saving time to spend more of it being
more productive just so you can get more
work done
i guess better advice is to prioritize
better
if you told 19 year old stephen bartlett
just to save more time he probably would
have
said no to a couple of things and then
just spent that saved time
working alone in his office all week and
all weekend
and that advice would therefore lead him
to a less joyful more depressive
existence and if you told 19 year old
stephen bartlett to
prioritize better the first question
that comes to mind is
what are my priorities and my long-term
priorities as i think is the case for
all of us
are ultimately linked to the things that
make our life meaningful which
are friends the joy of work our
relationships the satisfaction of
pursuing our goals
the challenge you know achieving greater
freedom
knowledge the pursuit of knowledge
health and fitness and i guess i would
have reviewed the allocation of my time
through that lens i would have saved
time only on the things that aren't
connected to my
macro priorities and reinvested it in
better places
and this year because we've you know
been forced to realize what matters
in many cases um i guess
now i'm not trying to save time just for
the sake of spending it more on
optimizing my productivity
i realize that that's an incomplete
sentence and really the most important
thing is just to prioritize all of my
time better
and allocate it to those things that
ultimately will matter the most
okay so the next question in my diary is
how do i maximize
my earning potential let me tell you a
little bit of a story
based on a friend of mine and his
company my friend has
a business which is listed on the stock
exchange
in germany one of the very small stock
exchanges in germany
and having spoken to banks and from my
own knowledge of how the stock market
and the public markets work
him and me both know that right now his
business is worth 1 billion
dollars because of the stock exchange
he's on if he moves his business
to the new york stock exchange the banks
and everybody knows that the valuation
will be four billion dollars it's the
exact same company
the exact same team the exact same
products the exact same mission
everything's exactly the same
but because he's on the wrong stock
market because he's on the wrong stock
exchange
the value is 25 of what it would be if
he just took that same business
the same people in the same products the
same skills the same experiences
and just moved it to a different stock
market and i i reflect on this analogy
as a wider
broader sort of life analogy because if
i look at
my career decisions over the last i'd
say 10 years i remember working in one
call center
in plymouth in devon where i was getting
paid about four pounds per hour
and for whatever reason i decided to
move to a different
call center with the exact same skills
the exact same experience and i got paid
10
times while i was getting paid at that
call center and this is what i've
started to notice in my own life is
i've had this particular set of skills
whether it's social media storytelling
marketing brands whatever you want to
call it
for the last i don't know maybe six
seven years
and as i've moved into different rooms
and different markets and different
companies and different industries
i've noticed that that exact same set of
skills is valued
completely differently and this made me
reflect with that story of my friend's
business in mind
that one of the questions you have to to
ask yourself sometimes in life isn't
just
you know how do i improve my skills but
it's like how do i maximize the earning
potential
for my skills and where are my skills
going to
give me the greatest reward let me give
you another analogy just to just to
cement the point
my ex-girlfriend my ex-ex-girlfriend is
a flight attendant and she currently
flies for emirates right
and emirates pay they pay okay right a
lot of lifestyle perks there but they
pay okay
she's told me that she'll get paid
up to ten times more if she manages to
get a job flying on private jets
because of tips and things like that the
same set of skills
ten times the return for the same set of
skills
if she can move her skills to a
different theoretical stock exchange if
you get what i'm saying
and this is just like one of the the
principles i've learned about life over
the
really over the last year um because
skills i was paid you know x amount for
a couple of years ago i'm getting paid
10 20
30 40 50 times for the same
set of skills just because i found a
market where those skills are more in
demand
they're higher valued and they're
probably more rare
and so that's something i think we can
all ponder which is asking yourself
where your skills
will reap the greatest return okay the
next question is do you have imposter
syndrome have you ever had it and can
you relate
and then there's a little question
underneath which is and how do i shake
this off
here's the thing whenever somebody does
something that's
outside of their zone of comfort and
that they don't have a ton of experience
in doing
we all feel the same thing right we all
feel that sort of
low-key inadequacy or that slight fear
but the reaction that everybody feels
and the way that we label that feeling
is completely different i actually think
it's how you label that feeling
that determines how you perform in that
scenario so some people will say
okay this is an exciting challenge i'm
going to learn i'm going to throw myself
at it i'm going to use that energy of
that i'm feeling those nerves or
whatever it might be
to focus some people will say oh my god
and they'll implode and they'll
try and retreat back into their zone of
comfort right
and so the response to that the feeling
is human
the response to it is optional if you go
through your life
avoiding situations that give you that
feeling of imposter syndrome
then i would bet everything that i have
that you aren't going to reach your full
potential
i genuinely believe the feeling of
imposter syndrome is both healthy
natural and a sign that you're putting
yourself in a position
where you're there's pressure which will
make you grow
and i've literally i can't think of a
moment in my life if you look at any
sort of two-year period in my life
where i didn't feel out of my depth
however that feeling of being out of my
depth never meant that i retracted from
the challenge it meant the exact
opposite it meant that i attacked the
challenge
i put more hours in i focused on it that
reaction is ultimately the reason why
you can hear my voice now it's the
reason i have this podcast
i very very unfondly remember the first
day
ever where i tried to make a video down
the lens of a camera in the microphone
and oh my [ __ ] god was that [ __ ] show
my friend tells me we should make a
youtube video it's about something
political so i sit in his house he turns
the cameras on puts a microphone on me
and i sit there and try and get just two
minutes of
spoken word out down this camera of the
lens and i sit there for seven
hours so much so that at the start of
this two minute video it's light outside
and it's sunny it's like the morning
by the end of this two-minute video if
you were to watch on youtube it's dark
outside and you can see stars
it took me that long right that long
because i was sat there feeling like an
imposter people aren't gonna give a [ __ ]
what i think
i'm an idiot i'm not sat there sweating
and ultimately it was my decision not to
let that sort of
knock me back and to swerve that being
in that uncomfortable situation ever
again
that's taken me to this place today
where i'm doing this podcast and there's
all these people that listen to it we've
got this youtube channel and all of
these wonderful things
and that is the defining thing it's not
about avoiding imposter syndrome that's
a very human thing
it's learning the art of embracing it
quick one starting from the minute the
lockdown is lifted we're gonna start
bringing in some of our subscribers to
watch how this podcast is produced
behind the scenes
means you get to meet the guests meet
myself and see how we put all of this
together
if you want that to be you all you've
got to do hit the subscribe button
okay so next question is how do you do
things you don't want to do
i've had i've had this crosstalk in my
mind a lot lately and i'll tell you why
because
i've committed myself to working out in
the gym downstairs
every single day and i have been going
every single day
for many many months now i think the
first time i started going gym
consistently was actually
march last year when all of this
craziness was uh thrusted upon us
but some days as i've talked about this
podcast i know people get tired of me
talking about the gym but it's just a
place where you learn so much about
yourself and discipline
and and your body and your brain and all
of that
so i always refer back to it but some
days i just
can't be bothered i can't be bothered to
go i can't be bothered to train hard
when
i'm there and um in many ways that's
kind of like synonymous of life there's
so many things in life that i just don't
want to do
and one of the thoughts that continually
gets me to the gym and continually makes
me show up and work hard
is this principle i live by which is
comfortable
and easy are like really short-term
friends but they're long-term enemies
and here's what i mean by that
comfort in the short term makes me feel
warm and fuzzy but then it might lead me
to being obese and having arthritis and
having high blood pressure and having a
heart attack in the long term
so like comfort and easy i just view so
anything that's comfortable and easy
like super comfortable and is you know
inherently avoiding
hard work or discomfort i kind of view
that
that decision or that thing with
skepticism i think you're trying to [ __ ]
me in the long term aren't you
and i genuinely cognitively have that
thought process sometimes when
my brain flutters and flirts with the
idea of oh just skip it steve you know
you don't really want to do that just
you know get an early night and swerve
that thing um
i think that's going to stab me in the
back one day in 12 months time or
10 years time that decision to choose
comfortable and easy as my friends
well they're going to become enemies and
they're actually not on my side
if you're looking for growth my general
principle
is to choose the challenge i'm not
saying choose the thing that you [ __ ]
hate i'm not saying choose the toxic
thing that's going to destroy your
mental health
i'm saying if you're looking for growth
and you're looking to
achieve the future that you you know you
envisage in your mind your ambitions
then you should choose the challenge and
and that's the thing that i continually
come back to
every time steve you know it hits 6 30
and i know i've got to go to go to the
gym in half an hour
and i'm manically busy and everything in
my head is saying make an excuse
no one will know go tomorrow just tell
yourself you'll go tomorrow you'll do it
another time
procrastinate or when i get to the gym
and i don't really want to show up and i
don't
want to work hard the same little
thoughts whisper in my brain but then i
think maybe that's the enemy
is that has have those thoughts really
got my long-term ambitions and my values
in mind
they nearly always haven't and that goes
back to the podcast i did with neil
where he says that you know when we try
and procrastinate or we convince
ourselves to do the things we don't want
to do
it's because of some kind of
psychological discomfort because i know
that these weights are heavy
and i know that it's uncomfortable and i
know that i'm tired and
those are if you are able to overcome
those moments
where it's easier to quit those are your
growth moments those are in fact the
most
valuable moments and this again comes to
another point which i always think which
is
the moments where i want to quit right
the days that are the hardest to get
myself
up and going are probably by definition
the most valuable moments to overcome
because that's probably
again thinking logically where most
people decide to stop
so you know that's where the greatest
returns are and i it sounds like
fluffy [ __ ] in hindsight no i think
this i think i think that in the moment
i think it before i go to the gym i
think
yeah this is this is the day when most
people wouldn't go
you know after the week you've had right
so hopefully that helps and
the conclusive point here is like you're
connecting yourself to who you want to
be
in those moments you're reminding
yourself of the person you want to
become and this
you know i read this on twitter i think
nine months ago but it stayed with me
ever since which is
how would the person you want to become
behave right now
and if you ask yourself in those moments
how would the person i want to become
behave right now what are the decisions
the person i want to be
would be making um that's usually a good
way to decide what the best answer is
right hope that helps okay so the next
question is a very
deep question it's what is the meaning
of life
very good question something i've
actually pondered a little bit over the
last
over the last year or so as i've i've
got more into
elon musk's work and space and his
motivations for wanting to
to understand meaning he actually says
that when he was really really young
he started pondering the meaning of life
and actually made him depressed and it
wasn't until he read hitchhiker's guide
to the galaxy that he
found some meaning um and optimism but
to to answer that question myself
i would say the meaning of life is to
create and live a meaningful life
i know that sounds like a bit of a
cop-out right but
in what you consider meaningful is
totally subjective and nobody can tell
you what that is or what it isn't
but i think you can spot it
when you get that feeling inside
yourself that your efforts are resulting
in progress
or outcomes that feel deeply worthwhile
and fulfilling to you
in any facet of your life whether it's
raising your dog or whether it's your
relationships or your work or whatever
it might be
and some people find that sort of
connection and meaning in building their
businesses
in writing in hobbies or you know
training their body through exercise or
raising kids or practicing their
religion one of the most important
things i've learned on this podcast
from interviewing guests and asking them
about the toughest moments in their
lives specifically guests that suffered
with
depression i remember we had dan murray
on the podcast who
had lost his father and talked about how
it wasn't until he did ayahuasca and saw
that the world was interconnected that
he refound his meaning
and we also had ben williams on the
podcast who said he was suicidal and
considering taking his own life
until he saw an advert to be a military
commando and
went off on that journey to pursue his
his intrinsic
career ambition of becoming a commando
that he found meaning in his life and
stability
and also from writing my book there are
some just crazy
mind-bending studies that i read about
in the preparation for my book
that totally changed my my thought
process on this
one of them right is studying johanna
hari's work
and the work he's done to understand the
true causes of depression and anxiety
and his work continually points to the
fact that depression and these
depressive feelings and this sort of
lack of orientation in life comes from
people who have had something happen to
them often who have lost
a sense of meaning through trauma in
their life not what's wrong with them
not because of some sort of chemical
imbalance in their brain
the other really sort of example that i
just can't shake that's in my book as
well
is this study they call rat park very
very simple
they took a group of rats they put them
in cages and they took all meaning from
their life
literally just a white cage on their own
and they gave them a choice do you want
to drink
heroin water or do you want to drink
normal water
the rats that are stuck in a white cage
alone become drug addicts right
then they have rat park which is this
rat utopia where there's
you know female and male rats there's a
little running machine where you can
exercise there's food there's a space to
to roam around and to explore
there's toys for stimulation and those
rats
don't become drug addicts when they're
offered either heroin or normal water
they avoid the heroin
if you zoom out a little bit and apply
the same thinking to humans
the science says that over the last two
years the life expectancy had dropped
between i think it's 2018 and 2019
because of opioid related deaths because
people are getting addicted to opioids
and that's resulting in their death and
and again that is because we have an
epidemic of meaninglessness
of purposelessness um that's what my
podcast has
taught me and that's what um that's what
my research in my book has taught me as
well
commonly prescribed antidepressants do
work for some people i think it's
important to
to sort of caveat my points with that
but adding additional meaning
and connection to your life does seem to
be one of the most powerful
antidotes for those feeling lost
depressed and unhappy and lacking that
orientation
and just to relate it to what we're
going through now with this pandemic
you know a lot of my friends have been
calling me and telling me that they're
feeling down
right they can't particularly describe
what exactly is causing them to feel
down but over the last three months in
particular as the uk has gone into this
i think third lockdown
i've really grown concerned about some
of my friends and the advice that i
continually give them
centers around the point i've just made
which is to find things
that will give them meaning life before
pre-lockdown
gave you meaning you you wake up in the
morning you go to the office you've got
colleagues and friends and then you
you know you go to the the club you go
to what's your favorite football team
player you go and see your mum and your
dad your grandparents
life was full of meaning before now it's
been pulled from you
so now it becomes your responsibility if
you want to you know maintain those
good feelings to go and get that meaning
right to go and create that meaning in
your life
you can't assume that it's just going to
show up like it used to so we and this
goes back to one of my points which is
when you really have to fight back you
have to go and get it and
you know i'll give you an example that
relates to me personally
the weekends right so my team and me we
work you know in this building through
the week
the weekends come around i have [ __ ]
nothing to do i'm a single guy
i have nothing to do it's me and my dog
right and he's not
a barrel of laughs to be honest he's
very simple guy so
he doesn't do an awful lot and so what
i've started to do on the weekends is to
really take time to pursue some of my
hobbies
which i would never normally do i've
started to dj all the time i'm now
learning to dj i do a dj lesson every
single weekend via zoom
i'm reading books that i used to love
reading philosophy books and i'm doing
this
actually not because i want to but
because i know i have to keep my life
full of like intrinsic
passions and meaning especially at a
time when so much of that has been
robbed by this pandemic so that's the
long way around the houses but for me
that really is the meaning of life
to create a meaningful life and um as i
say
in these times it's more important than
ever that you fight for that meaning
okay so the next question is a really
really great question which is
what is something you miss about being
poor that you think you'll never get
back
the stoic people used to talk about this
concept of
hedonistic adaptation and the hedonistic
treadmill and i'll give you
an example that's really easy to
understand i remember at 23 years old
when i took my first flight to thai i
think it was 20 21 years old
to thailand with my business partner dom
and i remember getting on that plane and
just like because because i'd never
really been on a plane before other than
when i was a baby coming over from
africa
i remember like being so in awe of the
fact that we were on this like
metal ship that was flying across the
ocean and they were like giving me
snacks and free water and do i want to
coke and i'm sat there in the economy
section
just like oh my god right
totally like full of like joy and
appreciation for everything
and the principles of like hedonistic
adaptations say that once you've been
exposed to a certain level of joy or a
certain level of like
i don't know gluttony or like you know
um material possessions
your satisfaction starts to decay over
time
and obviously as i got you know more and
more money and i got on flights every
week and then eventually i upgraded to
business class and then like first class
and
you know even got myself on a private
jet a couple of times your appreciation
for the small things
wanes the stoic people would take the
good things out of their life
as a practice just so that they would
appreciate them again and i think that's
one of the things that i definitely miss
i've got nice things all the time and
that is a
blessing and a curse imagine some rich
guy talking about
he's sick of nice things but there's
there's truth to that like you you lose
appreciation for
for things that used to mean so much to
you and when you look at
hedonistic adaptation in the hedonistic
treadmill you now require
even more to give you that same level of
thrill
and joy and satisfaction that's a really
sad thing it's kind of an unavoidable
thing to some degree
but with all things in life you can
really make a conscious effort to be
grateful
and to take moments not to let life pass
you by all these wonderful things pass
you by
so the other point is you know there's
that phrase ignorance is bliss and it
totally applies to
this question as well when i was 18
years old and i thought the meaning and
point of life
was to buy fast cars and to have a
million quid in the bank account and
to pursue those kinds of things there
was some bliss to that
i thought i had it figured out i thought
i understood that the pursuit of greater
happiness was just
more stuff more money and that was quite
blissful i didn't have it now
at 18 i didn't have it so i thought okay
that creates real meaning in my life
all i have to do is get more money and
then my life will be more meaningful and
you know full of joy and then upon
getting the money i realize that that's
not the case
and i i remember watching an interview
by the founder of
spotify danielec where he says the exact
same thing he's an insecure kid growing
up bit of a geek
and then he gets all this money not from
spotify but from the business before
and he has this deep existential crisis
where he's like
oh my god this wasn't it and
he had to then go on the journey of
finding out exactly what mattered to him
and i i'm still on that journey like i
still this is why i talk so much about
meaning and purpose in this podcast
because
i'm still figuring out like where i
should be prioritizing my time in order
to reap the greatest returns as it
relates to fulfillment
and i i think i didn't think about those
things when i was 18 and i was broke
but getting what you aim for is the best
way to find out if it's actually what
you wanted
and i was this young kid chasing
material things and and
probably passion mistaking it for
happiness as i got closer to it it moved
off into the distance like a
like a mirage or something or a rainbow
we all know that guy who like you know
has a two bedroom house
um in a small area he's married to his
wife one kid two kids
um looks forward to you know going to
the pub of the weekends and supporting
his favorite team
those individuals who live the most
simple lives and who are happier with
less
to me from my experience generally seem
to be much more fulfilled
than my friends that are successful
billionaires and my friends that are
billionaires
but also intellectuals and sort of like
low-key philosophers
are the most [ __ ] right because they
really have
got pretty existential and ask
themselves what is the purpose of life
that's what i mean by ignorance is bliss
and my third point in answer to this
question relates to
challenge when i was 18 years old
starting out in business living in moss
side in manchester
i had absolutely nothing i just dropped
out of university and i'm basically
stood at the bottom of this big
ambitious mountain that i've told myself
i'm gonna climb and i've told myself i'm
gonna accomplish
and i'm looking up at it excited
terrified
um but hopeful and yeah excited that's
that's the key feeling and then you
climb the mountain right the mountain
for me was like financial freedom it was
accomplishment
maybe for my ego it was like recognition
to some degree i have all of those
things now
and so when you get to this point where
you've
accomplished many of your goals you have
to
make a very conscious active effort
to create new even bigger goals goals
that will
match the same level of excitement and
challenge
that you had when you're 18 and it's not
easy because you don't become
financially free twice unless you lose
it all
right so my goals have to be way bigger
to give me that same level of like
hunger and uh grit and you know
determination that i need um to
to to to stay stabilized and to be to be
happy
and i guess it's a crazy thing to say
but to some degree
i miss like not being at the bottom i
miss not having those
massive this just mount everest in front
of me
and this is what i've seen in you know
many of my friends who are entrepreneurs
and even some of my idols is
when they get to that point when when
elon sold paypal or when
you know bill gates sold microsoft they
then go and take on some of these
tremendous you know philanthropic
challenges it's no surprise that every
billionaire becomes this crazy massive
philanthropist and tries to take on
some of the world's most existential
problems right it's no surprise
that elon is doing you know trying to
save the planet and take us to a new one
because he will not be able to find a
sense of fulfillment and happiness
in doing another paypal he just won't
find it and in many respects this is why
i think people who are tremendously
ambitious
have a bit of a curse i've spoken to a
lot of my friends that run businesses
you are obsessive about progress and
challenge and ambition and
reaching the next milestone and i think
a lot of them would actually if they
could just press a button
and trade their life for a much simpler
life someone who doesn't wake up every
single day and
check their whatsapp for 30 different
messages about their business on fire in
five different countries if they could
press a button and live a simple life
and be content in that life i think most
of them probably would
many of them would if they wouldn't
maybe they're twisted enough not to not
to realize that the meaning of life is
to be happy so if i gave them a
happiness button
maybe some of the psychopaths would
still opt for their current life
i've got one particular friend in mind
who i won't name
who sat me down about two years ago and
he's very very successful he's
probably a billionaire by now and he
confided in me that he wished his life
could be simpler
he wished he didn't have the level of
ambition he had he he
told me this one story about going
around to someone's house and they're a
very very normal family with not very
much at all and they just sat there
drinking tea and he said
i was sat there thinking i wish this was
my life this is a billionaire
with more sports cars than i've ever
seen in my entire life in one driveway
wishing he had a simpler life but
realizing that he is
infected with this virus which many of
us have
the ambitious the most ambitious amongst
us which stops you from
being happy with out pursuit
and without climbing that mountain
breaking news i have a new favorite
flavor of huel
about a month and a half ago they sent
me in the post
this white bottle with this sort of
sharpie red pen on it that said
top secret and i took it out i sipped it
probably shouldn't have because if
people send you things in the post like
that you probably shouldn't drink it as
your first reaction
you should confirm that they sent it but
i took it out i drank it
and it tasted amazing and now i'm i'm
very happy to announce that my new
favorite flavor of the hule ready to
drink
slow release carbs 20 grams of protein
vitamins minerals 27 essential vitamins
7 grams of
fiber per bottle is banana
which has just gone live on cure
and my friends know that i'm a massive
hulu again so they've been messaging me
all this week saying steve how good is
it is it good
and i've been telling them this is my
new favorite flavor which i think says a
lot so barry is now number two
and the new banana flavor ready to drink
huel
is my number one so yeah give it a taste
it kind of tastes like banana milkshake
but um banana milkshake isn't usually as
nutritionally complete so that's win
win win try it fiverr fiverr.com
i've talked about this a lot in this
podcast and um i just wanted to give you
a bit of an update i've
really really got into using fiverr over
the last couple of weeks and i think
if i was to estimate i've now had six
different
tasks completed on fiverr in the last
four weeks i've had two website builds
i've had
two decks made from designers that are
all around the world one is in venezuela
the other one is in
iceland i've had one logo made and one
video made
and to be honest i just wish i knew
about fiverr sooner in my career because
i think i would have been able to
accomplish more
in a much more cost-effective way okay
the next question i have here is what is
the most valuable skill you've learned
and how does that serve you now
um my mind bounced around to a few
different things when i read that
question but it came back to this this
this one
answer which kind of summarizes all the
other little points which is
sales and i genuinely believe sales
however you kind of want to define that
is the single most important skill in
the world i don't mean like selling
rolexes out your coat or
selling double glazing to a grandmother
on the phone
i mean the art of being able to persuade
other people to take an action right and
this is a skill that you will deploy in
a nightclub when you meet someone you
fancy
with your teams when you're trying to
build businesses with investors
every time you communicate in some
respect if you're trying to achieve a
certain outcome you are a salesman or
woman
and the art of being a good salesperson
is broken down into a bunch of different
factors there's
an understanding of you know having the
self-awareness to understand
how you're coming across having the
awareness to understand what the person
you're speaking to is after
it's how you carry yourself it's your
body language it's the way you speak
it's the energy you bring when you're
talking it's all of these small things
which are
very hard to to train into somebody but
for without shadow of a doubt sales is
the most important thing because
it's the skill that i use every day the
most right
and i want to answer the question like
how did i learn how to sell things i've
raised investment maybe 20 times maybe
more
probably more if you consider some of
the road shows i did when we took our
company public
one of the most important experiences i
had in my whole life was
i started working in a call center in
plymouth when i was
16 years old selling double glazing at
everest call center
and then i did that job until i was
about 18 and then moved to manchester
dropped out of university and then my
next 10 to 12 jobs
were all in call centers whether it's
because of my voice
or because um because of my skills with
selling i was just so good at that job
and i genuinely believe that that tele
sales experience i've had and i
genuinely would work in a telesales call
center
for three months make so much on the
bonuses that i'd quit this is why i've
had 12
teddy sales jobs i'd quit i'd spend the
next two months trying to build my
business
i'd then go back to another call center
make huge bonuses then i'd quit and i'd
keep doing that
but i genuinely believe that that
experience working in call centers
where you're honing this particular
skill which is calling someone
usually completely cold out of the blue
and
having to persuade them in less than a
minute to give you a chance or to buy
immediately
but to give you a chance to sell them
something that they didn't need
we all [ __ ] hate tele sales people
including me i just hang up immediately
these days because i'm so time poor
but if you got a chance to do one job in
order to improve your sales skills i
would highly highly recommend you do
either that
or even better which i did again when i
was in plymouth
door-to-door sales because that
introduces sort of
body language and other sort of more
physical communication skills
which uh which are even more relevant to
the world we live in today so
yeah sales is definitely the most
important thing and i often say to
people when they're
when they tell me that they've got an
offer to take one of two jobs
i'll often always prefer the sales role
especially if they're young and they
need to develop in that area because i
think it will
yield the greatest returns over the long
term i think getting good at selling
stuff
when you're young will yield tremendous
returns as a skill as you get older and
as i said at the start
sales applies to everything everything
and if you're good at it
if you're great at it then you might
just be great at everything
or at least be able to convince people
you are okay so the next question is
what is my greatest weakness and when i
first read this question
um a bunch of different things came to
mind in different sort of parts and
areas of my life so
i'm just gonna share as many of them
with you as i possibly can the first
thing that comes to mind
is i'm really bad at prioritizing
against the things that really matter to
me and i know that will matter long term
i've talked about this a lot in this
podcast i don't call my parents enough i
don't see my family enough
i probably don't give enough time in
person to like
meaningful friendships and connections
and those kinds of things and i know i'm
completely totally convinced that those
things are really really important
it's not that i don't understand the
importance of them it's that like my
work priorities always seem to be
just one you know one step higher on the
to-do list
my work has urgency to it there's no
urgency with calling my mom
right and that's kind of one of the
things i know is a weakness in myself
that i that i continue to strive to
to be better at is trying to prioritize
things that aren't urgent
but in the long term are really really
important the next thing
is in relationships i'm like really
self-centered i
i just want to do what i want to do and
i like
i am generally like really unwilling to
compromise
and that's an awful thing because
relationships are all about compromise
apparently so i've been told many times
um but i know it's a weakness of mine i
am
kind of like i kind of live the world in
my own head and if i want to just get up
and go and dj or walk down the street or
go in my room and just look at my laptop
and watch youtube videos doing that is
quite
hard when you're in a relationship and
you've got someone else to consider you
have to consider what they want and
you know the things that they want to do
that day and and also
in relationships generally i don't want
to do much because nine to five like
throughout the week my brain is [ __ ]
chaos so
on the weekend i'm not really all up for
doing much you know that's my down time
and that's become a real weakness of
mine and it's made forming
romantic relationships harder because on
the weekend i don't want to get out of
bed and if i do i just want to do some i
just want to do nothing
or something very very simple but the
problem i have there is through monday
to friday
i've spent all my time on my work so
saturday and sunday by definition like
logically have to be the time that i
commit to you as my partner so this is
why
i i continually struggle in
relationships because monday to friday
it's not about you
and on the weekend it's about me it's
about me and my down time watching
manchester united play
and i have to i have to learn to
compromise i'm sure a lot of people can
relate to that
the last thing would be because i'm so
mentally bombarded with a billion things
i have to do at all times
over the years the one thing that i've
definitely noticed in myself is i get
more and more
arguably rude
and to the point which is like when at
the start of my career i was very
i had more time and there were less
things like less tabs open in my brain
so i could take more time about how i
respond to things and i could be a
little bit more
fluffy and soft and whatever but when
you have
tons of urgent priorities your brain is
so funny i was i was talking to a friend
about this this morning in fact
and i was just giving some feedback to
one of the teams i'm working with
at another company because the ceo had
basically got in touch
and requested that all comms become much
more streamlined
because when we when the team were using
extra words
he basically to some degree gets you
know gets a little bit frustrated with
that because we're trying to move fast
as an organization
and i totally related to that i noticed
myself getting annoyed when anything
takes longer than it should and
this is something that's really changed
like totally changed in the last couple
of years
so i guess the thing that i have to be
aware of is that even in the situations
where i'm just desperately trying to
save time
is that i don't compromise on being a
decent human being
and i can't explain to you how hard this
is because we tend to have a philosophy
for how we act and how we behave and
that philosophy sits deep within us and
it whether it's a landlord showing me
around a new apartment or a new office
or whether it's an email or whether it's
a phone call
the philosophy tends to be the same
right and you it's hard to switch
between different philosophies
so i tend to treat very personal things
sometimes
in my personal life whether it's a
landlord showing me around an office
with the same rapid urgency
or my mum having a conversation with me
with the same rapid urgency that i might
treat business things and i need to get
better at like switching between the
context and
behaving differently in each scenario
and realizing that in some scenarios
the saving of the time is not more
beneficial than just remaining a decent
person and like engaging in the
situation
it's hard and i say it's hard not just
because of my own experiences
but i've seen pretty much pretty much
i'd say over 70 of the highly successful
people i know
become so incredibly impatient that it
almost verges on looking like rudeness
like they don't care about you um and
like they are
not present when you're with them now
this is a really hard point to explain
but i think people who are incredibly
busy will understand this
over the last couple of years i've
noticed that i've got incredibly
impatient with
um any request i get and it's something
i've noticed not just in myself but in
some of my friends who run very very big
really really sort of ambitious global
businesses who are constantly bombarded
with stuff
they are some of the most like
anti-social slightly rude people i've
met
you just can't get 10 seconds of their
attention and like just to give you
context of what's going on in my head
now
right now as i'm making this podcast i
know that i'm missing this phone call
with this pr firm
i know that i've got this major ipo
coming up with this one company i know
i've got this board meeting coming up
with this company i know i've got this
ipo coming up got this other
conversation about joining this board
and this other ip coming up
and i've got all these other personal
things going on in my life and this you
know i've got to record this podcast my
brain has just got all these tabs open
so when my pa walks up to me and she
goes hi steve how's your day going
you know shall i buy pablo some dog food
it just
it's just it's almost the only way i can
describe it is the question is like an
irritant
um and what you what i've got what
learnt over the years is like
i have to understand that people don't
understand
and i have to try and respond on that
basis which sometimes
especially when i'm like really tired
can be a challenge um something i've
really
tried hard to work on but i'm still like
really not that great at is
remembering to be like gracious and just
a decent person
irrespective of what's going on in my
head and treating people and being super
polite and trying to be my best self
every single day
in every interaction you know i i talked
on this podcast
once upon a time about the day i got on
a plane i sat in business class and i
look up and it's that guy from man
versus food
and we were running at the time one of
the biggest food publishers in the world
love food
and so i messaged the love food team
there was about 150 people that got this
message in the social chain chat at the
time
they said oh my god that guy from um man
vs food is on the plane
and they all said okay go up to him and
ask him this like famous social chain
question we have which is what's your
favorite sandwich
long story short when you join social
channel you get asked the question
what's your favorite sandwich
so i jump up and i walk over to his seat
in business class and i say
hey uh um i got quite boom shuts me down
not right now
like shouts in my face so i like slowly
tiptoe back to my seat in business class
i'm like slouched down
and then i have to message 150 people
saying oh by the way that guy we all
really like is an [ __ ]
um and he would have had no idea that he
was speaking to somebody who ran
at the time the biggest food publisher
in the world and had
hundreds of employees and at some you
know some point in the future might have
wanted to do some business with him or
work with him but now thinks he's a
total
[ __ ] and this for me that moment i'll
always remember
of as teaching me how important every
interaction is even the ones that don't
seem that important
um and i try and bear that in mind if
you've ever come and watched me speak
anywhere in the world which i'm sure a
lot of you have because i was a bit of a
speaking hoe over the last couple of
years
then you would have known that i never
ever would leave a venue before
everybody's got a chance to like
take a photo or meet me or ask me a
question i would be the last one to
leave my own talks
um because i that's the way that i would
want someone to treat me someone that i
followed and admired
that's how i would want them to treat me
and i'm scared of being an [ __ ]
um yeah and it's much easier to be an
[ __ ] when you're
when you've achieved some level of
success right powerful people find it
the easiest to be an [ __ ]
they can therefore also probably do the
most damage by being an [ __ ] but also
get away with it a lot of the time
i believe in being a good person as much
as i possibly can be and i'm like
clearly
imperfect in many many ways and i still
struggle with this but i'm doing my very
best to be a good person
um and to be kind and to you know
to never forget who i am and where i
come from okay so the next question is
i'm scared to post my business
online at the risk of failure or
humiliation
do you have any advice this is a very
interesting thing that i don't think
people talk about enough
especially when they're starting out in
business which is how do you overcome
the sort of public transition from just
being steve
to now being this entrepreneur who's
running this business and raising money
and
giving people advice and has has a
podcast how do you like square that with
especially in your friendships and your
personal circles with the person that
they
they knew first right and when we
started the business when we started
social chain my business partner dom
who's come on this podcast to talk about
it
was ridiculed by his friends privately
like
you know those kind of jokes that people
do where it's like a joke but it's also
not a joke
so he would post on his facebook page
saying we've just started social chain
just about this business it's going
really well or whatever he'd say
and like five or ten of his best friends
in the world
from his hometown would jump on there
with these kind of snide
jokey like patronizing
bantery comments uh but they were like
inherently mean comments
and i remember back in the day
continually jumping into his comment
section and trying to defend him and i'd
get some of my other friends to jump in
there and just be a bit nicer
he was posting his achievements and
being like ridiculed with like
not funny kind of funny banter and for
me as i reflect on what that actually
was
and the psychology behind his friends
and knowing his friendship group back
home
i'll be completely honest i think his
friends saw him changing
and somewhat didn't like who he was
becoming because
his success kind of alienated them and
nobody this is just a principle of
psychology that i've actually written a
little bit about in my book
people are most envious of people
who they can relate to so if you're you
know colleague at work or your friend or
someone your age is achieving
huge amounts of success and they look
like you and went to the same school and
came from where you come from that
inadvertently shines a mirror on you
it means you've got no excuse and that
your you know
success or lack thereof is probably a
consequence of your own actions and as
humans we just don't like that thought
and so dom's my business partner dom's
social circle back home many of them not
all of them there was one or two key
exceptions
we're trying to rein him in and saying
you know you're one of us
stay here don't become something that we
can't resonate with
and if you find yourself in the scenario
that dom did you basically have a really
simple choice to make it feels
complicated and it feels like a bit of a
minefield but it's not
the central question and the most
important question you have to ask
yourself
is who do i want to be and what makes me
happy
whether and this is a point you can
extrapolate to any sort of area of your
life even those outside of your career
who do i want to be and what makes me
happy and decide what that is
and pursue that thing anybody that you
lose in the pursuit of your happiness
is probably not someone you needed or
wanted in your life anyway they're
probably not someone that had your best
interests
which by definition are you being happy
at heart
they're probably someone who was riddled
with a little bit of jealousy
who didn't want you to become everything
you could become so that's the framework
in which you make your decision which is
who do i want to be and what makes me
happy
pursue that and be open to losing people
who no longer resonate with you pursuing
your happiness
along the way and i distinctly remember
going through this myself which is
facing
ridicule and banter and little snide
comments behind the scenes i remember a
day
where i posted something on facebook
like one of my quotes whatever it was or
some of my content on my daily vlog and
a friend of a friend
had made some snide little comment about
like who the [ __ ] does steve think he is
the friend had told me and it's those
moments where you can make that decision
to like fall back in light
line and conform and to avoid criticism
had i can you imagine my life if i'd
done that if i'd let a couple of
comments
stop me from pursuing my my career and
producing all this content which gives
me so much intrinsic joy and fulfillment
can you imagine if i let the fear of a
few comments
hold me back from my potential and the
things that make me happy
i'm so glad i didn't and in that
particular case
where that guy was ridiculing me behind
my back that same person four years
later
um when he went through some troubles in
his life and some mental health issues
reached out to me
because he was in love with my podcast
now and
uh met me in a sushi bar in london and
just sat there and asked me advice
because of something i'd said
on the podcast that he initially
ridiculed
and that kind of shows that that teaches
me a lesson that you know even some of
the people that ridicule you at the
start
you've kind of got to forgive whatever
it is in their nature
that's making them try and hold you back
but you've also got to understand that
it's not a you problem it's not your
responsibility to control what people
think of you in their head or
the image that they've created of you in
their mind that's not your
responsibility your central
responsibility as a human being is to
pursue
your happiness your truth and the things
that give you the most intrinsic joy
that's your responsibility and one of
the things i've come to learn about
success generally in life is that it's
the small
seemingly invisible seemingly
insignificant decisions
piling up over time that have the
greatest impact on you
it's not our big life choices it's the
small ones the ones that are easiest to
do or not to do
and it's the same with bending under
public pressure or criticism it's easy
if you see a friend of a friend slagging
you off just to stop doing that thing
if you allow these small seemingly
insignificant comments just
nudge you just one day at a time away
from the person you want to be and the
person you want to become
can you imagine how far you're going to
be from that person in 10 years time
it doesn't bear to think about people
ask me for book recommendations all the
time
and i finally got one for you it's a
book called happy
sexy millionaire which is authored by me
there's this crazy thing when you write
a book because you spend so much time
pouring your heart and soul into it and
everything you know and all of the
revelations you've had in your life
and then there's this barrier which is
that people have to buy the thing
in order for them to get that thing that
means so much to you i wish that wasn't
the case
it's just the way the industry is and in
order to get that distribution and to
get it on shelves you need a publisher
so
please please please if you can if
you've ever liked anything i've
ever produced this podcast my instagrams
anything i've ever said
read this book there was no ghostwriter
i wrote every single word myself there's
some real surprises in there it's an
honest sometimes hilarious incredibly
vulnerable
hopefully valuable recount of my life my
journey
everything i've learned across across
the way and really the answer to being
fulfilled to being happy and to
achieving success
it is the most important important thing
i've ever created so i implore you to go
to amazon now or wherever you get your
books
and get that pre-order if you get that
pre-order i'm going to put you into a
group with everybody that's pre-ordered
it
and i'm going to send you some exclusive
stuff so the first things i'm going to
do is a series of voice notes which i
think
are um are going to be pretty powerful
i'm going to give you access to some
tickets which nobody else will have
and i'm going to do everything i can to
thank you for for giving me that sort of
nine quid of your money or whatever it
is
happy sexy millionaire you can pre-order
it everywhere now and if you do get that
pre-order please do dm me because i'd
love to thank you myself
thank you so much for listening i feel
like i didn't i i don't say that enough
to all of you guys it means a ton
to me and honestly there'll be little
moments where i'm in the street or in
the gym or someone will say something
about the podcast
and it just puts this tremendous fire
under my belly to continue to do it
it requires a huge commitment and the
driving force behind that commitment is
all of your feedback
if you're listening on youtube hit the
subscribe button if you're listening on
the
the spotify or the podcast or hit the
subscribe button it means a ton to me
and it's more fuel for this movement um
and yeah it's the reason why we can keep
bringing you these episodes
and i'll see you again next week for
another installment of
[Music]